we've all heard that sales as a
lifeblood of any business and great
businesses who have their top-line
revenue constantly growing through these
three things better than their
competitors do here's what it is
step number one they have the best
finders number two they have closers
number three they have developers let me
tell you what each one of their roles is
finder is somebody who knows how to get
an interested by your a prospect a lead
a customer that wants to buy from you
they're very good at generating interest
the closer is somebody who has the top
20 FAQ of any product being sold so they
know it they know how to overcome that
objection they know how to address that
concern they know how to make sure the
customer feels comfortable buying the
product and then you have the developer
developer is somebody who goes back to
already an existing customer and says
are you happy with us how else can we be
of service what else can we do for you
is there any other thing you need with
us all three matter because this brings
more sales this consistently closes and
this keeps an opening of new flow of
customers wanting to buy now here's the
thing out of all the three do you know
which one matters the most out of all
the three because a lot of closers say
'under that's closer you know but they
only make $70,000 or you know why
because they're not the best finders
without finders there are no closers
there are no developers so always look
for many finders who know how to
generate new customers for your business
by the way if you know great finder out
there tag them in the video or share
this with them